it may not have attracted lines of
people around the block but Skyhigh has
become beloved by Disney fans for its
bright cheery tone and colorful
familyfriendly action though many years
have passed since the movie was released
enthusiasm for it and a possible sequel
has never waned on websites like Reddit
and Twitter fans of the original film
expressed their love and call for a
sequel nearly two decades later in 2020
a petition to get a sequel up and
running cropped up complete with an idea
on what it could be about the fan
proposed 2020 marks the 15 year
anniversary of the release of this Smash
Hit And we propose that the original
cast and creators of Skyhigh reunite for
a sequel depicting a high school reunion
featuring the characters we have all
adored for well over a decade even
though the petition didn't Garner as
much support as other fand driven
attempts to get movies made have its
mere existence demonstrates just how
passionate Sky High fans are when life
gives you
lemons make apple juice